programming throwdown episode 93 journey to programming mastery take it away jason i have andy and dave tech enthusiasts here to talk about their book, The Pragmatic Programmer. And this is a new edition of a book that's been around for a while, correct? 20 years. This is the 20th anniversary edition. Totally awesome. So why don't you go into sort of your background and what sort of inspired you to write the original book and then maybe what inspired you to revisit some of the things you talked about 20 years ago and we only have an hour right yeah that's true that's exactly you know dave and i could certainly give the the long
Programming Throwdown 第 93 期：编程精通之旅。Jason，交给你了。我有 Andy 和 Dave 这两位技术发烧友在这里，聊聊他们的书《程序员修炼之道》。这是一本已经出版很久的书的新版本，对吧？20 年了。这是 20 周年纪念版。太棒了。那么，你们能不能先介绍一下各自的背景，以及当初是什么启发了你们写这本书，还有是什么启发了你们在 20 年后重新审视书中的一些观点？我们只有一个小时，对吧？是的，没错，Dave 和我当然可以给出那个问题的长篇大论
answer to that question and we'd be here all day so we'll we'll try and give the uh the quick the quick version because i think a lot of people have heard this by now, too, as we've been talking about the new 20th anniversary edition. But this whole book came out. We really didn't intend to write a book. It was kind of an accidental book. We really just wanted to write a white paper for our clients at the time. So Dave and I were out doing consulting and noticing things people were doing out in the world, out in the workplace that, wow, that really hurts. That's painful. You know, there's a better way. Have you tried thinking of it this way? Have you tried experimenting with
答案，那样我们整天都待在这里了，所以我们会尽量给出简短的版本，因为我想很多人在谈论新的 20 周年纪念版时已经听过这些了。但整本书的出现，我们其实并没有打算写书。这算是一本偶然写成的书。我们当时只是想为客户写一份白皮书。Dave 和我当时在做咨询，注意到人们在现实世界、在工作场所做的一些事情，哇，那真的很糟糕。那很痛苦。你知道，有更好的方法。你试过这样想吗？你试过尝试
this? Have you tried using this technique? So what does painful mean? Is it painful in the sense that you paint yourself into a corner and now you have to rewrite everything? What would pain be when you're doing software development? Well, I think you have to think back to the 90s. And I know most of your audience probably wasn't born then. But the feeling in software in the 90s was one of really quiet desperation. Nothing seemed to be working. And the quality of software that was being shipped
这个吗？你试过使用这种技术吗？那么“痛苦”是什么意思？是指你把自己逼进死胡同，现在不得不重写一切的那种痛苦吗？当你进行软件开发时，什么是痛苦？嗯，我想你得回想一下 90 年代。我知道你们的大多数听众可能那时还没出生。但在 90 年代的软件行业，那种感觉是一种真正的、安静的绝望。似乎什么都不起作用。而且交付的软件质量
was honestly pretty much abysmal. And that was assuming it got shipped in the first place. The majority of software projects were canceled before they even got to the end. And a lot of the reason for that is that people were kind of floundering. They were taking on things without really knowing what they were doing. And then they were following some pretty random practices. So we were finding clients who were shipping software out to their clients without testing it, or who were not keeping their source code in version control. And so as a result, it it was like whose machine did we use last when it comes to like trying to reproduce a bug um or we actually had one client who had i think it was like 15 developers and each one of them we actually asked them all to build their product and no two builds were the
老实说，简直是糟糕透顶。而且那还是假设它最终能交付的情况下。大多数软件项目在结束之前就被取消了。这其中很大一部分原因是人们有点不知所措。他们在不真正了解自己在做什么的情况下就开始了。然后他们遵循了一些相当随意的做法。所以我们发现客户在没有测试的情况下就向他们的客户交付软件，或者没有将源代码放入版本控制中。结果就是，当试图重现一个 bug 时，就像是“我们上次用了谁的机器”；或者我们实际上有一个客户，我想大概有 15 名开发人员，我们实际上要求他们每个人构建他们的产品，没有两个构建是
same um you know this is kind of sad but but i've heard recent stories that sound just like this. Oh, yeah. It hasn't gone away. But I've got to tell you, I mean, compared to 25 years ago, we're in a much, much better state. We really are. That's good. So, yeah, we were working with clients who were in that kind of – I mean, typically you don't call a consultant in when everything is going well, right? So we were working with clients who were in that situation.
一样的。嗯，这听起来有点悲哀，但我最近听到的故事听起来就像这样。哦，是的。这种情况并没有消失。但我得告诉你，我的意思是，与 25 年前相比，我们的状况要好得多，真的好多了。那很好。所以，是的，我们当时正在与处于那种状况的客户合作——我的意思是，通常当一切顺利时，你不会请顾问，对吧？所以我们当时正在与处于那种情况的客户合作。
And we always found ourselves saying exactly the same fundamental things. You know, testing, version control, automation, talking to the customer. Taking small bites, not trying to take on too much at once just try this one little thing then try this next one little thing yep and that also means learning from each of those little things oh absolutely yeah it's no point in feedback unless you actually listen to it so uh we sort of we jotted notes down and it grew a little bit we got to i don't know 50 pages or so of notes. And the idea came through,
我们总是发现自己在说完全相同的基础知识。你知道，测试、版本控制、自动化、与客户沟通。小步快跑，不要试图一次承担太多，只尝试这一件小事，然后再尝试下一件小事。是的，这也意味着从每一件小事中学习。哦，当然。除非你真正听取反馈，否则反馈毫无意义。所以，我们记了一些笔记，它稍微增长了一些。我们大概写了 50 页左右的笔记。然后这个想法就出现了，
you know, we should probably write a book because this material is, you know, it's common sense, but it's not commonly used. So how do you go about, or how did you go about, because that's a completely different discipline. You have all of these notes, but how did you go about finding a publisher and things like that well so that's a that's a funny story um they were a little bit more than
你知道，我们或许应该写一本书，因为这些材料，你知道，是常识，但并没有被普遍使用。那么你是如何着手的，或者你们是如何着手的，因为那是一个完全不同的学科。你们有所有的这些笔记，但你们是如何找到出版商之类的呢？嗯，这是一个有趣的故事。它们不仅仅是
notes even in the earliest version i mean we had kind of notes but we had started you know writing them up in kind of a uh you know prototypical tip format like, here's an idea. Here's how you should do this. Here's this other idea. So we kind of had, you know, a loose structure to it right out of the gate. And somebody recommended, I think it was my, one of my brother-in-laws at the time said, because we knew nothing about writing books. We had, we didn't know how to proceed with that at all. But somebody suggested, you know, you go to your bookshelf and see the books that you like, you know, what is, what's the publisher that you are attracted to for professional titles in your, you know, in your area. And so Dave and I looked dutifully, and we both had a significant collection of Addison Wesley titles. They were pretty much,
笔记，即使在最早的版本中也是如此。我的意思是，我们确实有某种笔记，但我们已经开始以一种原型化的提示格式把它们写下来，比如：这是一个想法。你应该这样做。这是另一个想法。所以我们从一开始就有一个松散的结构。有人推荐，我想是我当时的某个姐夫说的，因为我们对写书一无所知。我们根本不知道该怎么做。但有人建议，你知道，去看看你的书架，看看你喜欢的书，看看在你的领域里，你被哪些出版商的专业书籍所吸引。所以 Dave 和我认真地看了看，我们俩都有大量的 Addison Wesley 出版书籍。它们几乎是
you know, the premier source for, premier source for computer science software development titles at the time. So we kind of randomly looked up the contact person and sent them an email and said, hey, we got this idea for a book. And they said, sounds great. We'll sign you up. That's awesome. I've heard so many stories like that. I think, I mean, one of the famous ones is I think Steve Jobs emailed the CEO of HP and asked for a computer or an internship or something like that. But yeah, it's fascinating that that really worked out well. You just you did some research, found the right person. And that's awesome. Yeah.
当时计算机科学和软件开发书籍的首要来源。所以我们随便查了联系人，给他们发了一封电子邮件，说：“嘿，我们有个写书的想法。”他们说：“听起来不错。我们签下你们。”太棒了。我听过很多这样的故事。我想，著名的故事之一是史蒂夫·乔布斯给惠普的 CEO 发邮件，要求一台电脑或实习机会之类的。但确实，这真的很成功，这很迷人。你们只是做了一些研究，找到了合适的人。这太棒了。是的。
And then it took us two man years, two and a half man years worth of work. No, no, no, no. It was more than that. It was well more than that because it was actually almost two elapsed years. That's true. It was almost two calendar years of both of us working just about full time, not out consulting, not doing any paying gigs, just sitting there concentrating on, okay, is there a better way that we could explain this? Could we make this clearer?
然后我们花了两个人年，两年半的人年工作量。不，不，不，不。不止这些。实际上远不止这些，因为实际上几乎是两个完整的时间年。没错。我们俩几乎全职工作了两个日历年，没有做咨询，没有做任何付费工作，只是坐在那里专注于：“好吧，有没有更好的方式来解释这一点？我们能让它更清晰吗？”
Is there a better word we could use here? And literally, Dave and I would argue over individual words to try to get our point across as best as we could. It's amazing how often Andy was wrong. Amazing what memory does to you over time. So, yeah, I wonder if you had some metrics from 20 years ago. Maybe you could see, you know, maybe the coin is flipped now on the other side or something. Maybe he was right the whole time. It's interesting because when we started this rewrite project, both Dave and I
“我们在这里能用更好的词吗？”字面上，Dave 和我会为了单个词争论不休，试图尽可能好地表达我们的观点。令人惊讶的是 Andy 经常是错的。随着时间的推移，记忆力真是令人惊叹。所以，是的，我想知道你们是否有 20 年前的指标。也许你可以看到，你知道，也许硬币现在翻到了另一面或者什么。也许他一直都是对的。很有趣，因为当我们开始这个重写项目时，Dave 和我
went away and said, okay, let's just make a list of what you think are the most important changes over the last 20 years. What are the topics that we have to revisit? What do we have to scrap? What do we need to introduce that wasn't an issue 20 years ago. So we each went off separately and made these lists and came back and put them together. And we were within probably 80% of what we had each come up with was exactly the same. So we were very much on the same pages. Yeah, this is a problem now. It wasn't a problem then. This was a good idea. We don't need to talk about that now, whatever it was. So we really had a great starting point to go through and begin to revise the text. Yeah, I definitely, I want to take a bookmark on that, but I think let's go into basically what is a programmatic programmer? What should people expect when they open this book?
都各自离开，说：“好吧，让我们列出你认为过去 20 年里最重要的变化。”哪些话题我们需要重温？哪些我们需要废弃？哪些我们需要引入 20 年前不是问题的话题。所以我们各自列出了这些清单，然后放在一起。我们大概有 80% 的内容是完全一样的。所以我们在很多方面非常一致。是的，这现在是个问题。那时不是。这是一个好主意。我们现在不需要谈论那个，不管是什么。所以我们确实有一个很好的起点来开始修订文本。是的，我绝对想在这里做个书签，但我想让我们进入本质：什么是《程序员修炼之道》？当人们打开这本书时，他们应该期待什么？
They should expect to get better at programming. All right. So what does that mean? Okay. So the thing is that programming is something that you have to do consciously. And a lot of people fall into programming somehow and it becomes a job and they do their work and they go home and it kind of like carries them along. And it's one of those industries where you can be carried along. But if that's all you do, you're never going to, A, you're never going to really enjoy it. And you're probably never going to progress as far as you could have progressed in terms of satisfaction in the job. So what we are recommending is to be more conscious of what you do as you're programming with a view to becoming
他们应该期待在编程方面变得更好。好的。那意味着什么？好吧，问题是编程是你必须有意识地去做的事情。很多人不知何故进入了编程领域，它变成了一份工作，他们做他们的工作，然后回家，它就像带着他们走一样。这是那种你可以被带着走的行业之一。但如果这就是你所做的一切，你永远不会，A，你永远不会真正享受它。而且你可能永远不会在工作满意度方面达到你本可以达到的高度。所以我们建议的是，在你编程时要更加有意识，以期成为
a better programmer. And so we have a whole bunch of separate topics that we talk about. Some of them are people topics, some of them are team topics, and some of them are technical topics. And there's probably about a fairly even division between those. And with each of them, what we try to do is to say, not you should do this, but instead we list alternatives and we suggest that you should try things. And with everything we suggest, what we're saying is we aren't in your environment. We don't know what you're doing. We don't know how you're doing. We don't know how you're doing
一名更好的程序员。所以我们讨论了一大堆独立的话题。其中一些是关于人的话题，一些是关于团队的话题，还有一些是关于技术的话题。它们之间大概有相当均匀的划分。对于每一个话题，我们尝试做的是，不是说“你应该这样做”，而是列出替代方案，并建议你应该尝试一下。对于我们建议的每一件事，我们想说的是，我们不在你的环境中。我们不知道你在做什么。我们不知道你是怎么做的。
it. But our suggestion is you might want to think about this, this, and this. And as you try them, gather feedback and work out whether or not that's improving or making things worse. And that's the pragmatic part of it because pragmatic fundamentally means doing what works. And so we have a list of suggestions and a list of, I guess, things from our experience. And then we say to people, you know, your mileage may vary, see if it works for you. Got it. But also your mileage may vary, but also you've firsthand, you know, tried a lot of these different strategies and policies in your consulting work, and you've sort of picked and chosen the best approaches? Well, no. I say yes, yes and no. Up until you said that last phrase,
但我们的建议是你可能想考虑这个、这个和这个。当你尝试它们时，收集反馈并弄清楚这是否在改善或恶化情况。这就是务实的部分，因为“务实”从根本上意味着做有效的事情。所以我们有一系列建议和一系列，我想，来自我们经验的东西。然后我们对人们说，你知道，你的情况可能会有所不同，看看它是否适合你。明白了。但你的情况也可能有所不同，而且你也亲身尝试过很多这些不同的策略和政策在你的咨询工作中，你算是挑选了最好的方法？嗯，不。我说“是，是和不是”。直到你说出最后那句话，
then I would say, yeah. I mean, these are all things that we've done because I really, really dislike consultants, if you like, who go around telling people how to do things that they themselves can't do. I have a story I tell. I was on a bus going to a conference in India from the airport, and I was sitting in the seat behind two fairly well-known industry experts on agile stuff. And they were talking, and one of them asked the other, when was the last time you programmed? And the other guy said, oh, I think it's about 15 years ago or so. You know, the other guy said, oh yeah, me too. And it's like, these are people that are going out and telling programmers every day how to program better and they couldn't code their
然后我会说，是的。我的意思是，这些都是我们做过的事情，因为我真的很讨厌那些到处告诉别人如何做他们自己做不到的事情的顾问。我有一个故事。我当时坐公共汽车从机场去印度参加一个会议，我坐在两位相当知名的敏捷领域行业专家的后座。他们在交谈，其中一个人问另一个人：“你上次编程是什么时候？”另一个人说：“哦，我想大概是 15 年前左右吧。”你知道，另一个人说：“哦，是的，我也是。”就像是，这些人每天都在告诉程序员如何更好地编程，而他们自己连代码都写不出来。
way out of a paper bag. So, you know, that's really bad. But when you say best, we don't actually believe that there is a best practice. We don't believe there is a best way of doing things because best is always going to be contextual. And so, you know, what's best for my environment could be totally wrong. If I'm making pacemakers and you're making video games, then I very much hope that our two development methodologies are very, very different. Yeah. It's similar to, you know, my PhD was on playing computer Go, having computers play Go. And there isn't, I mean, technically there's a perfect game of Go, but it can't be found and it's not very interesting. But what's really interesting is starting from random or starting from a not very good player and being able to get better and being able to iterate.
所以，你知道，这真的很糟糕。但当你提到“最好”时，我们实际上并不相信存在“最佳实践”。我们不相信存在做事的最佳方式，因为“最好”总是取决于环境。所以，你知道，对我环境最好的东西可能完全是错误的。如果我在制造心脏起搏器，而你在制作电子游戏，那么我非常希望我们的两种开发方法是非常、非常不同的。是的。这类似于，你知道，我的博士学位是关于玩电脑围棋，让电脑玩围棋。并没有，我的意思是，从技术上讲，存在完美的围棋游戏，但它无法被找到，而且它也不是很有趣。但真正有趣的是从随机开始，或者从一个不太好的玩家开始，能够变得更好，能够迭代。
And while you're iterating, continue to move in the right direction. I just feel like this is similar. Yeah, that's what it's about because I think one of the kind of foundational things that we misapprehend about the industry is just how dynamic everything is. You know, people tend to take a very static view of, you know, like you said, the best practice. Okay, I've learned this, now this is the best way to do it, this is what I'm going to do from here on out. That's a very static viewpoint and it's wrong because as soon as you say best practice, you're missing half the statement. Best for who? Under what circumstances? In what context? What are the parameters around that? We don't get around
当你迭代时，继续朝着正确的方向前进。我只是觉得这很相似。是的，这就是它的意义所在，因为我认为我们对这个行业误解的基础之一就是一切是多么动态。你知道，人们倾向于对“最佳实践”采取一种非常静态的看法，就像你说的，“好吧，我已经学会了这个，现在这是做这件事的最佳方式，从现在开始我就要这样做。”这是一种非常静态的观点，而且是错误的，因为一旦你说“最佳实践”，你就漏掉了半句话。对谁最好？在什么情况下？在什么背景下？周围的参数是什么？我们没有绕过
that. We get this kind of static view of, oh, I'll just do this one thing or I'll just learn this one programming language. When the book first came out, one of the tips in it was to help keep your knowledge up and to keep learning and to appreciate different ways of solving problems, we advocated you should learn a new programming language every year. Just, you know, something random. Learn a new, you don't have to use it in your job or a project, but just learn a new language and see how they approach different ways of solving these sort of common problems, different techniques. And we had people come up and say, well, that's a great idea, I love that, but what do you do after the first three years?
那个。我们得到了这种静态的观点：“哦，我只会做这一件事”或者“我只会学习这一种编程语言”。当这本书刚出版时，其中的一个建议是：为了保持你的知识更新，保持学习，并欣赏解决问题的不同方式，我们提倡你应该每年学习一门新的编程语言。只是，你知道，随便什么。学习一门新的，你不必在你的工作或项目中用到它，但只要学习一门新语言，看看它们是如何以不同的方式解决这些常见的类似问题，不同的技术。我们有人走过来说：“嗯，那是个好主意，我喜欢，但前三年之后你该怎么办？”
Because there's only, I mean, the only programming languages are pick some Java, PHP, Python, whatever, pick some Java, PHP, Python, whatever, pick some subset. It's like there's hundreds and hundreds of, some of which are really quite bizarre and quite interesting. But even the, what's the TiOB, TiOB index there, the top 50 on that are pretty interesting. Actually, no, I would disagree. I mean, I agree up to the TiOB interest index thing
因为只有，我的意思是，唯一的编程语言是——随便选一些 Java、PHP、Python 之类的，随便选一些子集。就像有成百上千种，其中一些真的很古怪，很有趣。但即使是，TIOBE 指数上的前 50 名也相当有趣。其实，不，我不同意。我的意思是，我同意 TIOBE 指数的事情，
because what that captures is what's current in fact not even what's current it's what's was hot over the last six months and that is basically if you're doing that then what you're doing is you're aiming at a wave that's already crested well yeah it's a trailing indicator, but it's something. Yeah, when we... I mean, coming back to languages, it's not the language that's important. And, I mean, the point that we both make a lot is that anybody who says,
因为那捕捉到的是当前的东西，事实上甚至不是当前的，而是过去六个月里热门的东西。如果你在做那个，那么你所做的就是瞄准一个已经达到顶峰的浪潮。嗯，是的，这是一个滞后指标，但它总归是点什么。是的，当我们……我的意思是，回到语言，重要的不是语言。而且，我的意思是，我们俩都经常强调的一点是，任何说“我是 Java 程序员”的人，
I'm a Java programmer, is actually saying I'm an idiot. Because you're not a Java programmer or a PHP programmer or a C programmer or a JavaScript. Or, even worse nowadays, programmer or a c programmer or a javascript or even worse nowadays i'm a react programmer right um it's like saying i'm a table carpenter right i just make tables that's it oh i'm a table carpenter slash saw division right yeah right i'm a hammerer yeah yeah exactly and so you're not you're not, you're a programmer. And so what learning languages
实际上是在说“我是个白痴”。因为你不是 Java 程序员、PHP 程序员、C 程序员或 JavaScript 程序员。或者，现在更糟的是，我是 React 程序员，对吧？这就像说“我是桌子木匠”，对吧？我只做桌子，就是这样。哦，我是桌子木匠兼锯子部门的。是的，没错，我是个锤子手。是的，是的，完全正确。所以你不是，你是一名程序员。所以学习语言
does, if you choose the right languages, is give you more depth in your craft. You get to experience different ways of thinking about a problem. So for example, right now I got talked into doing a, I'm doing a class down at SMU here in Dallas. So I'm teaching juniors and seniors. The class is called Programming Languages. And so I'm taking that as an opportunity to basically blow their minds by using languages from the 60s and 70s and showing them that, in fact, those languages were actually as capable, if not more capable, than 90% of the common languages today. Yep. You know, and it makes them think differently.
所做的事情，如果你选择了正确的语言，就是让你的手艺更有深度。你有机会体验思考问题的不同方式。例如，现在我被说服去参加一个课程，我在达拉斯的南卫理公会大学（SMU）上课。所以我正在教大三和大四的学生。这门课叫“编程语言”。所以我把它当作一个机会，基本上通过使用 60 年代和 70 年代的语言来震撼他们的思维，并向他们展示，事实上，那些语言实际上和今天 90% 的常用语言一样有能力，甚至更有能力。是的。你知道，这让他们以不同的方式思考。
You know, so I've taught them Snowball, and that kind of blew their minds. This week, in fact, in about three hours' time, I'm going to teach them Prologue. Oh, yes. And I can pretty much guarantee that that is going to open a few eyes, you know. And then what you can do is you can then look forward and look at languages that have, for example, pattern matching today or languages that reify their parameters and say, oh, I see where that came from now. You know? You can look at comprehensions and say, ah, okay,
你知道，所以我教了他们 SNOBOL，这有点震撼了他们的思维。事实上，本周，在大约三个小时后，我要教他们 Prolog。哦，是的。我可以保证那会让他们大开眼界，你知道。然后你可以做的是，你可以向前看，看看今天拥有例如模式匹配的语言，或者那些具体化其参数的语言，然后说：“哦，我现在明白那来自哪里了。”你知道吗？你可以看看列表推导式，然后说：“啊，好的，
I understand now why a comprehension is useful. So I think there's a lot of history and a lot of depth that we ignore. I mean, if you're an English major, then you don't spend your time writing, you spend your time reading. I mean, yeah, you write, but I mean, 90% of what you do is studying great works and not so great works and learning to be critical. Whereas when you're a developer, you spend no time reading the history and you spend no time exploring the depth. There is nobody talking about the Jane Austens of programming. Well, and you know why that is? Because
我现在明白为什么推导式很有用了。”所以我认为有很多历史和深度是我们忽略的。我的意思是，如果你是英语专业的，那么你不会把时间花在写作上，你会把时间花在阅读上。我的意思是，是的，你写作，但我的意思是，你 90% 的工作是研究伟大的作品和不那么伟大的作品，并学习如何进行批判。而当你是一名开发人员时，你花在阅读历史上的时间为零，你花在探索深度上的时间也为零。没有人谈论编程界的简·奥斯汀。嗯，你知道为什么吗？因为
most of the works that we see are not Jane Austen. They're more along the lines of, it was a dark and stormy night. But you know what? Suddenly, a shot rang out. Yeah. But even back then, that was 90% of the work, right? And what happens is history is a really, really good filter. And so if you've heard of somebody from the 19th century or the 18th century, then the chances are you've heard about them because they are better. They've risen to the top of that foam of noise. And the same thing is true for programming languages. I mean, Snowball and Prologue and Algol 60 and all those kind of things weren't the only programming languages
我们看到的大多数作品都不是简·奥斯汀。它们更像是：“那是一个黑暗而风雨交加的夜晚。”但你知道吗？突然，一声枪响。是的。但即使在那个时候，那也是 90% 的工作，对吧？发生的事情是，历史是一个非常、非常好的过滤器。所以如果你听说过 19 世纪或 18 世纪的某个人，那么你听说过他们的可能性很大，因为他们更优秀。他们已经从泡沫的噪音中脱颖而出。编程语言也是如此。我的意思是，SNOBOL、Prolog、Algol 60 和所有那些东西并不是当时唯一的编程语言，
back then, but they're the ones whose names have lasted because they actually have something to teach us. Yeah. I think one of the interesting things about programming is it's a science and an art, right? So if you look at, for example, science, people aren't going back to, you know, eighth century theories on the universe and on physics because science just kind of marches forward and obfuscates things as it goes. But art is a bit more timeless
但它们的名字之所以流传下来，是因为它们确实有东西可以教给我们。是的。我认为编程有趣的一点是它既是科学也是艺术，对吧？所以如果你看，例如，科学，人们不会回到 8 世纪关于宇宙和物理学的理论，因为科学只是向前发展，并在过程中掩盖了旧的东西。但艺术更永恒一些，
and people still refer to the best when they say the best poet they still refer to shakespeare who is you know so many centuries ago i don't know i mean so in this case you have both you have a science and an art but math see i got i got two things there first of all mathematicians do go back i mean people are still arguing about euclid's fifth postulate, right? And- Yeah, that's fair. That's fair. People are finding uses for Diophantine equations in quantum physics. There's all these kind of weird things that if you don't have the knowledge of the past, you don't know if you're missing
人们在说最好的诗人时仍然会提到莎士比亚，他已经是好几个世纪前的人了。我不知道，我的意思是，在这种情况下，你两者兼有，你既有科学也有艺术。但数学，看，我有两点。首先，数学家确实会回头看，我的意思是，人们仍然在争论欧几里得的第五公设，对吧？而且——是的，这很公平。这很公平。人们正在量子物理学中寻找丢番图方程的用途。有所有这些奇怪的事情，如果你没有过去的知识，你不知道你是否错过了
something. The second thing is, it always worries me when people say, is programming engineering? Is programming science? Is programming art? Because nobody ever says, is math basket making? It's math. It's mathematics is what it is. Why can't programming be what it is? Well, I think the reason for that is, and I agree, it is a problem because people are always trying to draw some kind of metaphor and say, oh, programming is, it is engineering, or it is just like building a house, or it is just like, you know, whatever, fill in the popular metaphor of the day. And it's none of these things. It has aspects of many of these things.
什么。第二件事是，当人们问“编程是工程吗？编程是科学吗？编程是艺术吗？”时，我总是很担心。因为从来没有人问“数学是编篮子吗？”它是数学。数学就是数学。为什么编程不能就是它自己呢？嗯，我认为原因在于，我同意，这是一个问题，因为人们总是试图画出某种隐喻，说：“哦，编程是工程，或者它就像盖房子，或者它就像，你知道，随便填入当天的流行隐喻。”它根本不是这些东西。它有许多这些东西的方面。
But, you know, fundamentally, if you think about it, the essential problem, I think, is that it's all, it is about thinking. It's about how you think of a problem, how you visualize it. You know, this whole idea of how do you abstract a problem and what parts you use and how are these parts going to cooperate to solve the problem, there's no physics that guides that. There's no chemistry behind that. There's no laws of gravity. There's nothing to sort of bound us in and say, well, you know, clearly it has to be this way or it's not going to work. You can do it any old half-assed way. You know, you can do it very procedurally in PHP. You can do it in a very OO style and in a real OO language like Smalltalk. You could do a functional style. And none of these have any kind of physical constraint or physical analog. It's literally just how you think about it. becomes really your time and your mental capacity of yourself and your team and how that evolves as the project evolves.
但是，你知道，从根本上说，如果你仔细想想，我认为核心问题是，这一切都是关于思考。它是关于你如何思考一个问题，你如何将其可视化。你知道，关于你如何抽象一个问题，你使用什么部分，以及这些部分将如何合作来解决问题的整个想法，没有物理学来指导它。背后没有化学。没有重力定律。没有什么东西来束缚我们，说：“好吧，你知道，显然它必须是这样，否则它就行不通。”你可以用任何半吊子的方式去做。你知道，你可以在 PHP 中非常程序化地做。你可以在真正的面向对象语言（如 Smalltalk）中以非常面向对象的风格做。你可以用函数式风格。这些都没有任何物理约束或物理模拟。它字面上就是你如何思考它。这真正变成了你的时间和你自己以及你团队的心理容量，以及随着项目的发展，它是如何演变的。
As the project evolves, does it get more and more just mentally demanding to the point where to change one line, you have to consult five people or have you sort of factorized it and has it become more elegant? But the constraint always seems to be a constraint of the mind and a constraint of the developer time it is it's definitely a constraint of the mind because one thing that happens the longer you're on a project and the more you're working with it the more you're learning the more you're realizing what you should have done in the first place right you, it's like this graph that starts off and at the very beginning of the project, you know, zero about it, you know,
随着项目的发展，它是否变得越来越费脑子，以至于要改一行代码，你必须咨询五个人，还是你已经将其因子化，它变得更优雅了？但约束似乎总是思想的约束和开发人员时间的约束。是的，这绝对是思想的约束，因为有一件事会发生：你在一个项目上待的时间越长，你与它一起工作的时间越多，你学到的就越多，你越意识到你当初应该做什么，对吧？它就像一个图表，从一开始，在项目刚开始时，你对它一无所知，你知道
absolutely nothing. Maybe there's a project title, maybe there's a name, you know, who else has been hired for the team, but you know, almost nothing about it. You know, the most about a project, about how it really should work and how it should have been done after you've shipped it, right? When it's all said and done, it's like, oh, okay, now I know enough about it. Now I realize, you know, maybe what we should have done better. So, okay, great. That's sort of how the real world works. Well, what can we learn from that? We can say that, well, you'd like to make your most critical decisions as late in the process as possible. Because the longer you wait, the more you actually know about it, the more you've learned, the more you can make an educated
绝对什么都不知道。也许有一个项目标题，也许有一个名字，你知道，团队还雇了谁，但你对它几乎一无所知。你对一个项目了解最多，关于它应该如何真正工作以及应该如何完成，是在你交付它之后，对吧？当一切都结束时，就像是：“哦，好的，现在我足够了解它了。现在我意识到，你知道，也许我们本应该做得更好。”所以，好的，太棒了。这就是现实世界运作的方式。好吧，我们能从中吸取什么教训？我们可以说，好吧，你希望尽可能晚地在过程中做出最关键的决定。因为你等待的时间越长，你对它了解得越多，你学到的越多，你就越能做出一个受过教育的
decision about what you're doing. So we try to defer decision making as long as possible, because up front, who knows? We have no idea. We haven't done it yet. And also try not to make critical decisions. Yeah, ever. Yeah, a decision that's reversible is not critical. A decision that's small, so you waste a week and not a year, is not critical. So if you can try to make a series of smaller, reversible decisions, then a lot of that risk goes away. One thing I'd say is you talked about, you know, it's a failure of the mind. I'm not a hundred percent convinced that that's necessarily true because that implies that an infinitely smart developer would be able to write perfect code. And that's not true because
关于你正在做的事情的决定。所以我们尽量推迟决策，因为在前期，谁知道呢？我们毫无头绪。我们还没做呢。而且也尽量不要做出关键的决定。是的，永远不要。是的，一个可逆的决定不是关键的。一个小的决定，所以你浪费了一周而不是一年，不是关键的。所以如果你能尝试做一系列更小的、可逆的决定，那么很多风险就会消失。我想说的一件事是，你谈到了，你知道，这是思想的失败。我并不百分之百确信这一定是真的，因为这意味着一个无限聪明的开发人员将能够编写完美的代码。那不是真的，因为
no one could. I think it's more, it's a failure of the spirit. It's a failure of courage. Because most developers actually know in their heart that they're hacking. If they're hacking, they know that they could be doing this better, but they're not willing to take a risk and to push back. So bootstrapping on that, this is something that's come up a lot personally.
没有人能做到。我认为更多的是，这是精神的失败。这是勇气的失败。因为大多数开发人员在内心深处实际上知道他们在“黑客攻击”（hacking）。如果他们在黑客攻击，他们知道他们本可以做得更好，但他们不愿意冒险并进行反击。所以基于此，这是我个人经常遇到的事情。
And I have pretty strong opinions on this, but I'd love to hear what you guys think. How do you deal with, you know, there's a lot of uncertainty when you're building something. And, you know, my philosophy is when there's a lot of uncertainty, you sort of compensate for that by trying to iterate quickly, aka hacking. But then you always remember that you're accumulating this debt and you go back once you have the certainty, maybe you have the product market fit for your app, then you go back and rewrite the whole thing. And you do it knowing that that was the price that you were going to pay. Other people feel that you should never rewrite anything. You should have good standards in place to where you don't have to do that. What's your opinion on that whole tradeoff?
我对这一点有很强的看法，但我很想听听你们的想法。你如何处理，你知道，当你构建某样东西时有很多不确定性。而且，你知道，我的哲学是当有很多不确定性时，你通过尝试快速迭代来补偿，也就是黑客攻击。但随后你总是记住你正在积累这种债务，一旦你有了确定性，也许你为你的应用程序找到了产品市场契合点，然后你回去重写整个东西。你这样做，知道那是你将要付出的代价。其他人认为你永远不应该重写任何东西。你应该有良好的标准，这样你就不必那样做。你对整个权衡有什么看法？
I think that kind of conflates a couple different issues there. You can certainly turn out something very quickly without hacking or having something low quality. You can very deliberately put something together that is a prototype, that you know is a prototype and its purpose is for learning. That's not a waste of time, that's not a waste of engineering, and that doesn't even have to be in software. You can do a prototype with wireframe diagrams for a website. You can use post-it notes on a whiteboard. The idea is to get in front of the user, the sponsor, somebody who can comment on this and learn what it is you're trying to explore.
我认为这混淆了几个不同的问题。你当然可以在不进行黑客攻击或拥有低质量东西的情况下非常快速地完成某事。你可以非常刻意地把某样东西放在一起作为一个原型，你知道它是原型，它的目的是为了学习。那不是浪费时间，那不是浪费工程，甚至不必是软件。你可以用网站的线框图做原型。你可以在白板上使用便利贴。这个想法是出现在用户、赞助商、可以评论这一点的人面前，并了解你试图探索的是什么。
So you don't have to write a crappy version of the product to do that, to get that fit, to get that information. You can very deliberately say, okay, well, we don't really know how the user is going to handle this or what they'll think about this. So here's a prototype. Let's try this. And then you can go in, you know, sort of armed with full engineering and do the real version. But you can kind of have both. You don't have to write crappy code just to get feedback. Got it.
所以你不必为了做到这一点、为了获得那种契合、为了获得那些信息而编写一个糟糕的版本。你可以非常刻意地说：“好吧，我们真的不知道用户将如何处理这个，或者他们会怎么想。”所以这是一个原型。让我们试试这个。然后你可以进去，你知道，带着完整的工程武装，做真正的版本。但你可以两者兼得。你不必为了获得反馈而编写糟糕的代码。明白了。
That makes sense. The other thing is that prototyping is very different from end-to-end developing. In the book, what we do is we differentiate between something we call prototyping and something we call tracer bullet development. So prototyping is when you're unsure of a particular thing. And it could be a UI element. It could be an algorithm. It could be anything. And so the idea of the prototype is to maximize the amount you learn.
这很有道理。另一件事是原型设计与端到端开发非常不同。在书中，我们所做的是区分我们称之为“原型设计”的东西和我们称之为“示踪子弹开发”（tracer bullet development）的东西。所以原型设计是当你对某件事不确定时。它可以是一个 UI 元素。它可以是一个算法。它可以是任何东西。所以原型的想法是最大化你学到的东西。
And so what you do when you start is you set an objective to say, you know, I need to know, is this algorithm twice as fast as that one or whatever it might be? And you basically ignore all of the niceties of programming just to answer that one particular question, knowing that when you finished, and this is the part that takes an incredible amount of discipline, when you finished, you record your results, and then you throw the code away because it's a prototype. Yep, yep. And that's very hard to convince the stakeholders, but that's something that a good tech lead should do up front.
所以当你开始时，你设定一个目标说：“你知道，我需要知道，这个算法是否比那个快两倍，或者不管它可能是什么？”你基本上忽略了编程的所有细节，只是为了回答那个特定的问题，知道当你完成时——这是需要极高纪律性的部分——当你完成时，你记录你的结果，然后把代码扔掉，因为它是一个原型。是的，是的。这很难说服利益相关者，但这是好的技术主管应该在前期做的事情。
Well, you can also make it clear that this is not shippable, especially if you're just doing PDF wireframes of a site. Clearly, you can't ship that. That's not usable. Think back to the old days of Detroit when they used to model cars, right? And if they were doing wind tunnel tests, they'd probably build a car out of plywood and clay, and they could stick it in a wind tunnel and see how it behaved.
嗯，你也可以明确表示这是不可交付的，特别是如果你只是在做网站的 PDF 线框图。显然，你不能交付那个。那不可用。回想一下底特律的旧时代，当他们过去给汽车建模时，对吧？如果他们正在进行风洞测试，他们可能会用胶合板和粘土造一辆车，他们可以把它塞进风洞，看看它的表现。
No one would want to take a plywood and clay car out on I-95. So, you know, clearly that's a prototype and that's what we're aiming for when we do prototypes. However, the other side of that is sometimes you actually need a way of seeing how your whole development hangs together. So maybe you're using a new front-end technology you've not used before and a new backend web framework you haven't used before. And you need to know how that hangs together in your particular context. And for that, we recommend doing something different, which is to do an end-to-end thing extract, if you like, of your actual final application. And you don't worry about anything apart from getting the database
没有人会想把一辆胶合板和粘土做的车开上 95 号州际公路。所以，你知道，显然那是一个原型，这就是我们做原型时所追求的目标。然而，另一面是，有时你确实需要一种方法来看看你的整个开发是如何结合在一起的。所以也许你正在使用一种你以前没用过的新前端技术和一种你以前没用过的新后端 Web 框架。你需要知道它在你的特定环境中是如何结合在一起的。为此，我们建议做一些不同的事情，即做一个端到端的东西，如果你愿意的话，是你实际最终应用程序的提取物。你除了让数据库
to talk to the back end, to talk to the front end, to talk to the user, whatever it might be. So there'll be no error checking. There'll be no anything apart from this, let's get a crack in this wall that's in our way. And you make that crack and you see if it's the right way of doing things and then you build from it and we call it tracer bullet because it's the same way that you know if you watch these old war movies when people are firing machine guns in the dark
与后端对话，与前端对话，与用户对话，不管它可能是什么，什么都不担心。所以不会有错误检查。除了这个，让我们在这个挡路的墙上开个裂缝之外，不会有任何东西。你制造那个裂缝，看看它是否是做事的正确方式，然后你从它构建，我们称之为“示踪子弹”，因为它和你知道的一样，如果你看这些老战争电影，当人们在黑暗中发射机枪时，
they use you know every nth bullet will be a tracer bullet that glows and so they can see where their bullets are heading and that's exactly what we want to do in software development. Yeah, that makes a lot of sense. I think, yeah, as you kind of said, the biggest thing is when you have the wood and clay car, because with software, the wood and clay car, it's not as transparent, but that's where, as I said, a good tech lead will say,
他们使用，你知道，每第 N 颗子弹将是一颗发光的示踪子弹，这样他们就能看到他们的子弹正朝哪里射去，这正是我们想在软件开发中做的。是的，这很有道理。我想，是的，正如你所说，最大的事情是当你拥有木头和粘土车时，因为对于软件，木头和粘土车，它没有那么透明，但这就是我所说的，一个好的技术主管会说，
no, this thing is being held together with uh with with clay you know we need to go back and rebuild it well that and that comes back to a matter of communications that we haven't really talked about yet but you know the biggest things that that you do as a software developer right the job is problem solving you know it's not coding java it's not coding javascript whatever it is problem solving. It's not coding Java, it's not coding JavaScript, whatever. It's problem solving. But in order to do that, there's an awful lot of communication going on. And it's not just talking to a user or interviewing a user, but it's communicating with the team,
“不，这个东西是用粘土粘在一起的，你知道，我们需要回去重建它。”嗯，这又回到了我们还没真正谈过的沟通问题，但你知道，你作为软件开发人员所做的最大的事情，对吧，工作是解决问题，你知道，它不是编写 Java，它不是编写 JavaScript，不管它是什么，它是解决问题。但为了做到这一点，有很多沟通在进行。而且不仅仅是与用户交谈或采访用户，而是与团队沟通，
communicating with the sponsors. It's about learning all the time from the system as it's evolving under your fingers, learning from the team as you work together and build this thing, learning from the users, because they may not know what they want before you show them something, right? There's that kind of like, you know, Heisenberg uncertainty principle with users. As soon as you put software in front of them, they realize what they really wanted was something else. So, you know, this is all, again, it's very dynamic, very ongoing process where you're communicating, you're learning, and you're solving problems.
与赞助商沟通。它是关于一直从在你指尖下演变的系统中学习，在你们一起工作和构建这个东西时从团队中学习，从用户那里学习，因为在向他们展示某些东西之前，他们可能不知道他们想要什么，对吧？有那种，你知道，海森堡不确定性原理与用户。一旦你把软件放在他们面前，他们就意识到他们真正想要的是别的东西。所以，你知道，这一切，再次，是非常动态的、持续的过程，你在沟通，你在学习，你在解决问题。
That's what the job sort of comes down to, I think. Yeah, that makes sense. Let's jump to something else. What about another sort of, I'm going to go through basically a lot of the great debates that I've seen over the years and get your take on it. And I feel like a lot of them will relate to the book, but feel free to tell me it doesn't. But how do you handle
我认为工作归根结底就是这样。是的，这很有道理。让我们跳到别的事情上。关于另一个，你知道，我打算经历我多年来看到的许多伟大的辩论，并听听你们的看法。我觉得其中很多会与这本书有关，但如果它无关，请随时告诉我。但你如何处理
interviewing? We have this great debate where what we do is we bring candidates in, we ask them to invert a binary tree, solve some NP complete problem that has some trick to it that makes it polynomial. And then they never have to use those tricks ever again. And so you end up with almost this secret language. You have to come into the company, do the secret handshake that shows that you have this algorithmic genius from, in my case, I don't know, 10 years ago when we were in college. And then you get the job where you do nothing like that. How do you interview better? I think that's not, I mean, I think that approach in general is nonsense. Because again, you're not testing for competency
面试？我们有这个伟大的辩论，我们所做的是我们把候选人带进来，我们要求他们反转二叉树，解决一些 NP 完全问题，这些问题有一些技巧使它变成多项式。然后他们再也不用使用那些技巧了。所以你最终几乎得到了这种秘密语言。你必须进入公司，做那个秘密握手，表明你拥有这种算法天才，来自，在我的情况下，我不知道，10 年前我们在大学时。然后你得到了一份你做的事情完全不像那样的工作。你如何更好地面试？我认为那不是，我的意思是，我认为那种方法通常是胡说八道。因为再次，你不是在测试能力。
on what your actual expectation is. Because the job is not sitting around inverting binary trees or you know whatever the interview questions might be i think if if you can make the investment if you've you know identified a strong candidate and you want to see if they're if they have the the chops for it you invite them to sit with the team for a day and you watch them work and you see how do they get along with people how do they they work? What style do they have? At the end of that day, the team gets to decide whether they hire this person. Oh, interesting. Yeah, exactly. You know, ironically enough, we do exactly that for internal transfers where that's rather frictionless.
取决于你真正的期望是什么。因为这份工作并不是坐在那里反转二叉树，或者你知道的任何面试题。我认为，如果你能投入时间，如果你已经确定了一位优秀的候选人，并且想看看他们是否有能力胜任，你可以邀请他们和团队一起工作一天，观察他们如何工作，看看他们如何与人相处，他们的工作风格是什么样的。在那一天结束时，由团队决定是否录用这个人。哦，有意思。是的，完全正确。你知道，讽刺的是，我们在内部调动时就是这么做的，而且过程相当顺畅。
But at least in my experience, it's never been practical to do that with an external candidate. But yeah, I agree with you. For internal, that's definitely the way to go. I feel like that might be tough, right? I've done it for external. What makes it hard? Well, I mean, there's kind of a ramp up. Also, I guess it might be good as like a final round.
但在我的经验中，对外部候选人这样做从来都不切实际。不过，我同意你的观点。对于内部人员来说，这绝对是最好的方式。我觉得这可能很难，对吧？我为外部候选人做过。难点在哪里？嗯，我的意思是，有一个适应期。另外，我想这作为最后一轮面试可能不错。
A lot of candidates might not want to come back for that day. I guess it depends on the job market and many other factors. If a candidate doesn't want to do that, then you don't want to hire them. It's true. Because a candidate who doesn't want to know what it's actually like to work there is like crazy if you ask me and you wouldn't want to hire that person that makes sense so but let's say uh you know i do think a lot of companies you know want to have the person in for one day um oh i guess so so if you could only have a person for one day that that would be the day they would just sit with you and then and you
很多候选人可能不想回来参加这一天的工作。我想这取决于就业市场和许多其他因素。如果候选人不想这样做，那你也不想雇佣他们。确实。因为如果一个候选人不想知道在那里工作到底是什么感觉，在我看来这很疯狂，你肯定不想雇佣那样的人。这说得通。那么，假设……你知道，我确实认为很多公司希望候选人来工作一天……哦，我想也是，所以如果你只能让一个人来一天，那这一天他们就应该和你坐在一起，然后你
would do that instead of in lieu of all the other interviews. I think you'd have one, maybe a 20-minute. Okay, so all the research I've read have said that you can pretty much sum up your feelings about a candidate in the first, it's ridiculously small, it's like two seconds or five seconds, right?
会这样做，而不是代替所有其他的面试。我想你会有一次，可能20分钟的面试。好吧，我读过的所有研究都表明，你基本上可以在最初的几秒钟内总结出对候选人的感觉，时间短得离谱，大概两秒或五秒，对吧？
And they've had people actually record their opinion at those very, very small times and then go through the entire rest of the day. And it turns out their initial impression is typically the correct impression. So you have them come in and talk to whoever, you know, HR, someone in a suit, whoever it might be, just to weed out the clear whack jobs, the people who you wouldn't want to hire just because. And use your instinct, use your intuition. If you're good at this, then your intuition is the best judge, right? A programming test is irrelevant because you don't turn up at work
而且确实有人记录了他们在那些非常非常短的时间内的意见，然后继续进行剩下的一整天。结果发现，他们的第一印象通常是正确的印象。所以你让他们进来，和任何人谈谈，你知道，人力资源部，穿西装的人，或者任何其他人，只是为了剔除那些明显的怪人，那些你仅仅因为直觉就不想雇佣的人。相信你的直觉。如果你擅长这个，那么你的直觉就是最好的评判标准，对吧？编程测试是不相关的，因为你上班时
and have your boss say, okay, everybody in the team, here's an NP complete problem. You know, it's that way. So what's the point of doing that during recruiting? But instead, you know, what you do have to do every day is to turn up, learn new things, work with a team, not be a jerk, you know, and, you know, generally have hygiene. And to do that, the only way I can see to do that is you overcome the initial hurdle of being acceptable to HR, and then you actually work with the team. Yeah, that makes a lot of sense. You say there's a ramp up. Of course, there's a ramp up.
不会有老板说，好了，团队里的每个人，这是一个NP完全问题。你知道，就是这样。那么在招聘时做这个有什么意义呢？相反，你知道，你每天必须做的是准时上班，学习新事物，与团队合作，不做一个混蛋，你知道，并且，你知道，通常保持个人卫生。要做到这一点，我能看到的唯一方法就是你克服了人力资源部门的初步门槛，然后你真正地与团队一起工作。是的，这很有道理。你说有一个适应期。当然，有一个适应期。
But the reality is the time of people that you want to hire, typically you want them to be able to ramp up. You want them to be able to go into an environment and learn what's needed to be learned. Now they're not going to be experts in the domain and the team is not going to throw them into the most mission critical part of it, but they are going to have to show that at the end of the morning, at least, they now know enough to be productive at some level so i mean i think this is fascinating i haven't thought about this you know this this method but to play a bit of devil's advocate um you know that um there might be some people who are sort of slow starters but sort of get in a good rhythm there might be other people who kind of have a lot of energy early on and then kind of get burnt out. Would you be sort of favoring that second group, which is not really a good thing? Well, it's a different axis because the, you know, solve the trivia question on the board isn't going to tell you that either. That's true. If anything, that favors the people who prepare to interview, which is probably worse. That's all it does. That's actually all it does. It's the people who found the cheat sheet on
但现实是，你想要雇佣的人，通常你希望他们能够适应。你希望他们能够进入一个环境并学习需要学习的东西。现在他们不会成为该领域的专家，团队也不会把他们扔到最关键的部分，但他们必须在上午结束时至少证明他们现在知道得足够多，可以在某种程度上提高效率。所以我认为这很迷人，我没有考虑过这个方法，但为了唱反调……你知道，可能有些人起步比较慢，但进入状态后节奏很好；也有些人可能早期精力充沛，然后就精疲力竭了。你会偏向第二组吗，这其实不是什么好事？嗯，这是不同的维度，因为你知道，在白板上解决琐事问题也无法告诉你这一点。确实。如果有的话，那反而偏向于那些为面试做准备的人，这可能更糟。这只是它所做的。这实际上就是它所做的。是那些在YouTube上找到作弊表的人
YouTube or wherever. It said, okay, here's the questions. This is what Google asks, or this is what Netflix asks, or whoever. And here's the good responses. Here's the answers. So, okay, you can identify that they've got some initiative and some research capability that they bothered to look up the answer. But that's all it's going to tell you. Yep. I have a friend who has a pretty morbid view of this. His view is basically that you can't hire effectively. And so all you can do is fire effectively. And so there's some companies, I won't name any names, but there's some companies where that's kind of their strategy, where they're relatively loose on the hiring. But then there's a pretty, there's sort of some unwritten rules about, you know, firing what they consider the bottom 10% after a year or something like that.
或者其他地方。上面写着，好吧，这是问题。这是谷歌问的，或者这是Netflix问的，或者其他任何人问的。这是好的回答。这是答案。所以，好吧，你可以确定他们有一些主动性和研究能力，他们费心去查找答案。但这就是它能告诉你的全部。是的。我有一个朋友对此有相当病态的看法。他的观点基本上是你无法有效地招聘。所以你唯一能做的就是有效地解雇。所以有些公司，我不点名，但有些公司就是这种策略，他们在招聘上相对宽松。但随后有一些不成文的规定，关于，你知道，解雇他们认为一年后表现最差的10%左右的人。
Yeah, I've heard about that. And I think the problem with that is that a company has to be a safe place, I think, in order for a team to be effective. If a team is spending their whole time worrying about a set of performance numbers, then that's going to be their focus as opposed to solving the problem. I've heard about a company that does exactly as you described, that at the end of the year, the bottom 10% get culled, which technically is decimating, which is kind of fun. And I've heard of managers in those organizations that adjust their priorities in order simply to make something by the end of the year that gets them back up into whatever the performance goal is. And that totally destroys what the team was doing.
是的，我听说过。我认为这其中的问题在于，我认为公司必须是一个安全的地方，团队才能有效。如果一个团队把所有时间都花在担心一系列绩效数字上，那么这就是他们的重点，而不是解决问题。我听说过一家公司完全按照你描述的那样做，在年底时，表现最差的10%会被裁掉，这在技术上是“十分之一抽杀”，这很有趣。我听说过这些组织中的经理调整他们的优先级，仅仅是为了在年底前完成某些事情，使他们回到任何绩效目标之上。这完全破坏了团队正在做的事情。
So, yeah, I think there's merit in that, and I think a company has to be able to reposition or fire people that just do not work for that company. But at the same time, I think this kind of like mechanical, you know, the slowest 10% we just, you know, leave behind is the wrong kind of motivation. It's the danger. It's the danger of metrics. And I mean, there's literally whole books written on how you can kill your company by slavishly following metrics. Because as Dave was indicating, any metric you set up, people will find a way to game it. And they will work only toward that metric and lose sight of the actual business value, the actual reason the organization is there. Just look at standardized testing in schools. Yeah. Yeah.
所以，是的，我认为这有其价值，而且我认为公司必须能够重新定位或解雇那些根本不适合该公司的员工。但与此同时，我认为这种机械的，你知道，最慢的10%我们只是，你知道，抛弃，是错误的激励方式。这是危险。这是指标的危险。我的意思是，字面上有很多书写的是关于你如何通过盲目遵循指标来扼杀你的公司。因为正如戴夫所指出的，你设定的任何指标，人们都会找到方法来操纵它。他们将只朝着那个指标工作，而忽略了实际的商业价值，组织存在的实际原因。看看学校里的标准化考试就知道了。是的。是的。
Teach to the test. Exactly. That's right. Yeah. I feel the same way that you do, Dave. I feel like my team is kind of my family. I wouldn't go and tell one of my children, well, you got an F on this test. Why don't you go down the road and live on that house over there? you're out of the family um uh and uh so yeah i totally agree um
为了考试而教。完全正确。没错。是的。我和你有同样的感觉，戴夫。我觉得我的团队就像我的家人。我不会去告诉我的一个孩子，好吧，你这次考试不及格。你为什么不搬到路那边的房子去住呢？你被逐出家门了……呃，所以是的，我完全同意……
so actually let me ask you this and there's this sort of idea of this you know pareto distribution when it comes to engineering talent like everyone says oh i want this mythical 10x engineer and so i'm going to hire like crazy fire like crazy do this this really bizarre thing because i'm trying to look for that needle and do you believe that that there is sort of that sort of Pareto distribution that some people are just you know coming in doing 10x there is but they're kind of looking at the wrong axis because the way that that's commonly interpreted is you're looking for the individual performer who can be 10x better than anyone else,
所以实际上让我问你这个，有一种关于工程人才的帕累托分布的想法，每个人都说，哦，我想要这个神话般的10倍工程师，所以我打算疯狂地招聘，疯狂地解雇，做这种非常奇怪的事情，因为我试图寻找那根针。你相信存在那种帕累托分布，有些人只是，你知道，进来做10倍的工作吗？存在，但他们看的维度不对，因为通常的解释是你正在寻找那个可以比其他人好10倍的个人表现者，
and that's actually not what you want because that person is probably a phenomenal jerk. Not easy to work with. For real, seriously. What you want is you want the performer who can come in and make the team work at a 10x level. So why is the 10x person a jerk? I mean, I know people like that, but just broadly speaking,
而这实际上不是你想要的，因为那个人可能是一个极其糟糕的混蛋。很难共事。真的，严肃地说。你想要的是那个可以进来并使团队以10倍水平工作的表现者。那么为什么10倍的人是混蛋呢？我的意思是，我知道那样的人，但从广义上讲，
why are those people jerks? Because the slow people get in their way, right? They know that they could be coding really, really fast. But having to fill out all these stupid forms gets in their way. Having to, or even worse, having to answer all these ridiculous, stupid questions from people who could just look it up, right? That gets in their way. And quite often, there's actually a little hidden problem, and that is when someone gets to a certain level of expertise, the knowledge they have, okay, there's a whole bunch. I could go on for a long time about this, or Andy could better than I could.
为什么那些人是混蛋？因为慢的人挡了他们的路，对吧？他们知道他们可以写代码写得非常非常快。但必须填写所有这些愚蠢的表格挡了他们的路。必须，或者更糟，必须回答所有这些来自本可以自己查阅的人的荒谬、愚蠢的问题，对吧？这挡了他们的路。而且通常情况下，实际上有一个隐藏的小问题，那就是当某人达到一定水平的专业知识时，他们拥有的知识，好吧，有很多。我可以就此谈很长时间，或者安迪比我能谈得更好。
But it's all to do with the fact that the real processing power in your brain is the non-conscious part of your brain. And the conscious part is just kind of like window dressing that lets you interact with the rest of the world. So when you're first starting, in a particular area, all of your processing is being done by your conscious brain because you're having to think about everything you do, like when you learn to drive or whatever it might be. And that means it's slow. And that's why when people first start to drive, they're very jerky and they're slow to respond and all that kind of stuff. But after a while, the information starts to get embedded in your non-conscious brain as tacit knowledge. And at that point, you start to operate more by reflex.
但这都与这样一个事实有关：你大脑中真正的处理能力是你大脑的非意识部分。而意识部分只是某种装饰，让你与世界其他部分互动。所以当你刚开始在一个特定领域时，你所有的处理都是由你的意识大脑完成的，因为你必须思考你所做的每一件事，就像你学习开车或任何其他事情一样。这意味着它很慢。这就是为什么人们刚开始开车时，他们非常生硬，反应迟钝，诸如此类。但过了一段时间，信息开始作为隐性知识嵌入到你的非意识大脑中。在那一点上，你开始更多地凭反射行事。
And that's why an experienced driver can drive without even thinking about it. Same is true for experts in any field. So if you become an expert programmer, then it's because you've put in the hours and you've used the feedback and you now make decisions, not at the conscious level, but down deep somewhere in the lizard brain. And as a result, when someone says, why did you do that? The answer is probably, I don't know. It was still a good decision, but it was made without conscious thought. And that is also very disruptive to a team because you have this person who can just basically do things and not know how or why, which means he can't tell or she can't teach the rest of the team what they're doing. But Andy's point is a really good one. If you want to make a team 10 times more effective, or sorry, if you want to get the equivalent of a 10 times increase on a person's performance, if you have a team of 10 people, all you have to do is bring
这就是为什么有经验的司机可以在不假思索的情况下开车。任何领域的专家也是如此。所以如果你成为一名专家程序员，那是因为你投入了时间，并且你利用了反馈，现在你做出的决定不是在意识层面，而是在蜥蜴脑深处的某个地方。结果，当有人问，你为什么那样做？答案很可能是，我不知道。这仍然是一个好的决定，但它是在没有意识思考的情况下做出的。这也对团队非常有破坏性，因为你有这样一个人，他基本上可以做事却不知道怎么做或为什么做，这意味着他不能告诉或她不能教团队其他人他们在做什么。但安迪的观点非常好。如果你想让一个团队的效率提高10倍，或者抱歉，如果你想获得一个人表现10倍的等效提升，如果你有一个10人的团队，你所要做的就是带
in a manager who can make each individual in that team twice as effective. And you can do that. So maybe just to recap, I think what you're saying is if you're off using your lizard brain, using your unconscious memory and writing code like crazy, and you're not taking it to the conscious space, that's what's giving you the 10x, but that's also just blowing up the people around you because ultimately you need to communicate and you need to be conscious to sort of work as a team. And also sometimes your unconscious is just going to do things because it has seen this situation in the past 17 times and it's going to say, okay, this is the way to do it. And it might not be appropriate the 18th time. Yeah. That's, that's the big risk because you know, you're the expert is relying on intuition and lots of the time they're right, but not necessarily, they could be very wrong and they could develop something now that no one else on the team can understand and can't fix.
进一位经理，他能让团队中的每个人效率提高一倍。你可以做到这一点。所以也许总结一下，我想你所说的是，如果你在使用你的蜥蜴脑，使用你的无意识记忆并疯狂地编写代码，而你没有把它带到意识空间，这就是给你10倍效率的原因，但这也只是炸毁了你周围的人，因为最终你需要沟通，你需要有意识地作为团队工作。而且有时你的无意识只是会做事情，因为它在过去17次见过这种情况，它会说，好吧，这就是做它的方法。而在第18次时它可能不合适。是的。那是，那是巨大的风险，因为你知道，专家依赖直觉，很多时候他们是对的，但不一定，他们可能非常错误，他们现在可能开发出团队中其他人无法理解且无法修复的东西。
Yeah. This is, you know, this is a bit of a tangible, bring it back, is I know somebody who was working in finance, and they were using rather old machine learning techniques. And I said, what about using some of these newer techniques? What they told me was that they tried it, and for six, seven months, they were making more money. But then the eighth month, they took a huge hit, just had some really bad decisions.
是的。这是，你知道，这有点切题，把它带回来，我知道有人在金融领域工作，他们使用的是相当古老的机器学习技术。我说，使用一些这些新技术怎么样？他们告诉我的是，他们尝试了，并且有六、七个月他们赚了更多的钱。但在第八个月，他们遭受了巨大的打击，只是做出了一些非常糟糕的决定。
And there were decisions that were unexplainable. And so because of the lack of explanation, lack of interpretability, they ended up dropping back. They would rather make less money, but at least know what was going on. And so that's another example where, yeah, someone has to sort of really kind of communicate. Another thing is there's a lot of people who don't want to do good peer reviews.
而且这些决定是无法解释的。因此，由于缺乏解释，缺乏可解释性，他们最终退回去了。他们宁愿赚更少的钱，但至少知道发生了什么。所以这是另一个例子，是的，有人必须以某种方式真正地沟通。另一件事是，有很多人不想做好的同行评审。
And, you know, my sort of philosophy on that is if you read your code and the peer reviewer reads your code, right away that's twice as many people reading the code than writing it. So it's only going to multiply more than that. I would say, actually, if you read your code, that's an infinite number of more people reading it than typically happens. I don't know. No, seriously, how many developers stop and reread their day's output the next day?
而且，你知道，我对此的哲学是，如果你阅读你的代码，同行评审员阅读你的代码，马上就有两倍的人在阅读代码，而不是编写代码。所以它只会成倍增加。我实际上会说，如果你阅读你的代码，那阅读它的人数比通常发生的要多出无数倍。我不知道。不，严肃地说，有多少开发人员停下来并在第二天重读他们一天的产出？
Yeah, not very many. Not very many. Think how much, given that peer review or code review is the most effective way of finding bugs, just think how much more productive people would be if the first thing you did in the morning was get a cup of coffee, sit down, and
是的，没几个。没几个。想想看，鉴于同行评审或代码审查是发现错误的最有效方法，想想如果早上的第一件事是喝杯咖啡，坐下来，然后
read yesterday's code. Yeah, that makes sense. With a clear head and fresh eyes. Fresh eyes can make all the difference. Yeah. What about, how do you sort of reward, you know you know this is getting more into the social part of it I guess maybe the corporate part of it but how do you serve reward good engineering you know like you could say that it rewards itself but then the problem is now assigning that reward becomes difficult right it's almost like the person who
阅读昨天的代码，人们会提高多少效率。是的，这说得通。头脑清醒，眼光新鲜。新鲜的眼光可以带来所有的不同。是的。那么，你如何奖励，你知道，你知道这更多地进入了社交部分，我想也许是企业部分，但你如何奖励好的工程，你知道，就像你可以说它奖励了它自己，但问题是现在分配那个奖励变得困难了，对吧？这几乎就像那个
manages the the nuclear power plant you know, it just becomes someone that doesn't really get thought of a lot. How do you sort of develop the right incentives and the right sort of structure to really reward people for taking that extra time to be conscientious? What do people want? What do people want? Yeah. See, I'm doing the consultant trick there. I'm taking your question. They want autonomy and mastery, Dave. Oh, thank you, Andy.
管理核电站的人，你知道，它只是变成了一个不怎么被想到的人。你如何制定正确的激励措施和正确的结构来真正奖励人们花额外的时间去尽职尽责？人们想要什么？人们想要什么？是的。看，我在那里使用了顾问技巧。我正在拿你的问题。他们想要自主权和精通，戴夫。哦，谢谢你，安迪。
I mean, that's exactly right. I mean, if you want to give people motivation, you give them more of the stuff they enjoy, right? And you make it, you create an environment in which it's enjoyable to create cool stuff, good stuff, the stuff that you want created. And if that's the case, then you can reward people by giving them more of it. I think you have a bit of a tragedy of the commons where what people want is to sort of do things that have some impact. So maybe people want to use a new framework. Someone else wants to get more people to visit their website. And what happens is people might want to write good code,
我的意思是，那完全正确。我的意思是，如果你想给人们动力，你给他们更多他们喜欢的东西，对吧？并且你使它，你创造一个环境，在其中创造酷的东西、好的东西、你想要创造的东西是令人愉快的。如果是这样的话，那么你可以通过给人们更多它来奖励他们。我认为你有一点公地悲剧，人们想要的是做一些有影响的事情。所以也许人们想要使用一个新的框架。另一个人想要让更多的人访问他们的网站。而发生的事情是人们可能想要写好的代码，
but that want ends up becoming secondary to some of these other wants. Those motivations are all facing exactly 180 degrees away from where they should be right what people i believe what people really really want most people who go into software development do it because they want to produce something that other people can use they want to be useful right they want they want there's a thrill involved in shipping software and knowing that two people are using it, or in some cases, a hundred million people are using it. And you're making a difference. If you're a Twitter or a Facebook or whatever else, you are changing the world. People are organizing revolutions on your platform, right? People are organizing hate campaigns on your platform. Whatever it is, you're changing the world. And so people who are in those
但那个愿望最终变得次于其他一些愿望。这些动机都完全背离了它们应该面对的方向，180度，对吧？人们，我相信人们真正真正想要的，大多数进入软件开发的人这样做是因为他们想要生产其他人可以使用的东西，他们想要有用，对吧？他们想要，他们想要，交付软件并知道有两个人正在使用它，或者在某些情况下，有一亿人正在使用它，这其中有一种快感。而且你正在产生影响。如果你是Twitter或Facebook或任何其他东西，你正在改变世界。人们正在你的平台上组织革命，对吧？人们正在你的平台上组织仇恨运动。无论它是什么，你都在改变世界。所以那些在那些
environments should be given that feedback. They should get to know that, yes, you are making a difference in the users of your software's lives. Because once you know that, I can't think of anything more motivating than getting out there and helping out. You're in know that, I can't think of anything more motivated than getting out there and helping out. We are kind of like little godlike beings on this planet in that we're one of the few industries that can take nothing and create something from it. I mean, yeah, we use But it's sort of an opportunity cost. So piggybacking on that, someone can say, well, you know, I just wrote this this this prototype. I built it out of wood and clay assembly code and I can go and do the have the discipline to go and rewrite that. Or I have this new idea for changing the opinions or changing improving the lives of these hundred million people.
环境中的人应该得到那种反馈。他们应该知道，是的，你正在改变你的软件用户的生命。因为一旦你知道了这一点，我想不出比走出去并提供帮助更令人振奋的事情了。你知道，我想不出比走出去并提供帮助更令人振奋的事情了。我们在这个星球上有点像小神一样，因为我们是少数几个可以无中生有的行业之一。我的意思是，是的，我们使用……但这是一种机会成本。所以顺便提一下，有人可能会说，好吧，你知道，我刚刚写了这个原型。我用木头和粘土汇编代码构建了它，我可以去拥有纪律去重写它。或者我有这个关于改变观点或改变改善这一亿人生活的新想法。
And I'm going to do that instead. And then a year later, the wood and clay thing falls apart, right? So yeah, Kent Beck, have you seen Kent Beck's talk on that? The three X's? No, but I'll add it to the show notes. Okay, because Kent Beck has a talk about his time at Facebook where he talks about the different cultures of the different parts of the organization.
而我打算那样做。然后一年后，木头和粘土的东西散架了，对吧？所以是的，肯特·贝克，你看过肯特·贝克关于那个的演讲吗？三个X？没有，但我会把它加到节目说明中。好的，因为肯特·贝克有一个关于他在Facebook时光的演讲，在那里他谈到了组织不同部分的文化。
And you have the people building the clay prototypes, right? And you have that high churn, high risk, high return kind of experimental side of it. And then you have at the other side of the curve, the we better not screw up because it will kill the business part of the company, right? And they have very different objectives, very different ways of managing it, very different ways of measuring success. And the interesting part is the curve that goes between the two of them and how things transition up and down that curve. And I think that that addresses what you're talking about. I think if you have a person or a team that really, really enjoys churning out ideas and are really, really bad at all of the polishing and everything else that takes place, that's
你有建造粘土原型的人，对吧？你有那种高流失、高风险、高回报的实验性一面。然后在曲线的另一边，我们最好不要搞砸，因为它会杀死公司的业务部分，对吧？他们有非常不同的目标，非常不同的管理方式，非常不同的衡量成功的方式。有趣的部分是连接他们两者的曲线，以及事物如何在那条曲线上上下转换。我认为这解决了你正在谈论的问题。我认为如果你有一个人或一个团队，他们真的真的喜欢大量产出想法，而在所有其他发生的润色和其他一切方面都非常非常糟糕，那
great. You have yourself a little factory of really cool ideas. Then you have on top of that people who can filter, who can do the A-B testing and all the other kind of stuff, at the end of the day say, you know what? That really was a really great idea. Let's make it look good or let's make it manageable or maintainable or whatever else you need to be able to do. So don't kill the team who's being imaginative just because they're using clay. And this goes back to what we talked about right at the very beginning.
太棒了。你拥有了一个非常酷的想法的小工厂。然后你在那之上拥有可以过滤的人，可以做A-B测试和所有其他那种事情的人，在一天结束时说，你知道吗？那确实是一个非常棒的想法。让我们让它看起来不错，或者让我们让它可管理或可维护，或者你需要能够做的任何其他事情。所以不要仅仅因为他们在使用粘土就扼杀那个富有想象力的团队。这回到了我们一开始谈论的内容。
It goes back to context, right? One size doesn't fit all. It's perfectly okay to have one team that is the imagination factory and one team that is the solid, reliable, engineering with Erlang never fail kind of, I mean, whatever. That's what's best for them is not best for the other. And that's as it should be, right? Every context is different.
这回到了背景，对吧？一种尺寸并不适合所有人。拥有一个作为想象力工厂的团队和一个作为坚固、可靠、工程与Erlang永不失败的团队，我的意思是，无论什么，这完全没问题。对他们来说最好的不是对另一个最好的。而且本应如此，对吧？每个背景都是不同的。
That makes sense. So, I mean, with that in mind, yeah, you really need to have a good engineering discipline all the way up through the stack of, through the leadership in the organization, right? Because there has to be somebody high up that says, you know, we have all of these prototypes. Now we need, we need a team that is that has a different incentive to make sure that, that you know, that, that, we don't end up with just wood and clay when we're done that we have,
这说得通。所以，我的意思是，考虑到这一点，是的，你真的需要从上到下，通过组织中的领导层，拥有良好的工程纪律，对吧？因为必须有高层的人说，你知道，我们有所有这些原型。现在我们需要，我们需要一个团队，它有不同的激励措施来确保，你知道，我们最终不会只剩下木头和粘土，当我们完成时，我们有，
that we have the solid foundation as well. Well, unless your business is making wood and clay, in which case you're all set. Sure. Yeah. Fair enough. Fair enough. I mean, it depends, right? There are companies that do that. Like Xerox PARC, for example, right? Yep.
我们也有坚实的基础。嗯，除非你的业务是制造木头和粘土，在这种情况下你一切准备就绪。当然。是的。有道理。有道理。我的意思是，这取决于，对吧？有公司这样做。例如，施乐帕洛阿尔托研究中心，对吧？是的。
They spin off the skunk works and, you know, they spend their entire lives producing nothing more than prototypes. And then the rest of Xerox looks on and say, hey, we could productize that, you know, and do so. So let me ask you this. So what do you know, so someone who runs, let's say, you know, a lot of the people listen are, you know, fresh out of college or changing industries or things like that. And I remember when I first got into the software engineering industry, I kind of thought in my naivete, I thought tech leads were just people who didn't work as hard. And I thought managers were people who didn't do anything. And directors were people who posted on social media about the company.
他们分拆出臭鼬工厂，你知道，他们一生中除了生产原型什么都不做。然后施乐的其余部分看着并说，嘿，我们可以将其产品化，你知道，并这样做。所以让我问你这个。所以你所知道的，所以运行的人，假设，你知道，很多听众是，你知道，刚出大学或改变行业或类似的事情。我记得当我第一次进入软件工程行业时，我有点天真地认为，我认为技术主管只是工作没那么努力的人。我认为经理是那些什么都不做的人。而总监是那些在社交媒体上发布关于公司信息的人。
That's obviously not true. But, you know, so we talked about one thing that, let's say, directors, maybe even vice presidents or CTOs have to do, which is sort of setting up teams with different incentives. What do you think, just more broadly, that tech leadership at a company does? They support their team. The point of a tech leader, I think, is to run ahead of the team just a little bit and sweep all the debris out of the way so the team can move smoothly and efficiently through to completion. It depends on what phase of a project you're in as to what that involves. At the very beginning, it could well be setting architectural overall directions. A good tech lead will act more as a referee than as a dictator when it comes to that. But then later on in the project, a tech lead will be running interference with management. We'll be making sure that the team is producing whatever artifacts are necessary and fighting back the requirement to produce artifacts that aren't necessary. Fundamentally, the tech lead is a servant of the team.
那显然不是真的。但是，你知道，所以我们谈论了一件事，假设，总监，甚至副总裁或CTO必须做的事情，那就是设置具有不同激励措施的团队。你认为，更广泛地说，公司的技术领导层做什么？他们支持他们的团队。我认为技术领导者的意义在于跑在团队前面一点点，把所有的碎片扫开，这样团队就可以顺利高效地完成任务。这取决于你处于项目的哪个阶段，这涉及什么。在最开始，这很可能是设定整体架构方向。一个好的技术主管在涉及这一点时会更多地充当裁判而不是独裁者。但后来在项目中，技术主管将与管理层进行干预。将确保团队正在生产任何必要的工件，并抵制生产不必要工件的要求。从根本上说，技术主管是团队的仆人。
But notice, notice again, that's a very dynamic description. It changes over time. It's not a static, just do this one thing. You know, at this one point, the role changes depending on, you know, the life cycle of the project and even the organization. It's, you know, once again, it's a very dynamic approach. Yeah, that makes sense. What about somebody who wants to get into the industry? We get a lot of emails from people who, you know, they want to know, should I go back to college, get another four-year degree in some cases? Should I do this boot camp XYZ? Should I just go on GitHub and start cloning, you know, forking repos and learning that way?
但请注意，请注意，那是一个非常动态的描述。它随时间而变化。它不是静态的，只是做这一件事。你知道，在这一点上，角色根据，你知道，项目的生命周期甚至组织而变化。它，你知道，再一次，这是一个非常动态的方法。是的，这说得通。那么想要进入这个行业的人呢？我们收到很多来自人们的电子邮件，他们，你知道，他们想知道，我应该回到大学，在某些情况下获得另一个四年制学位吗？我应该做这个训练营XYZ吗？我应该只去GitHub并开始克隆，你知道，分叉仓库并以那种方式学习吗？
You know, but ultimately the goal for most of the people who write in is to get a job, right? So with that as the goal, how could somebody, you know, get started if they didn't, you know, get a CS degree or they didn't go through that process? May I? So I think that there is a use for CS degrees, but that use is not preparing someone for a job in the industry. There is a theoretical side to computer science that you probably need to learn if you want to go into research and move the goalposts a bit further forward. For getting into the industry, I don't think you're particularly well served by a CS degree. I see people graduating CS degrees who have never written a unit test in their life. Oh, yeah, Probably the majority. Yeah. Who couldn't organize, you know,
你知道，但最终大多数写信来的人的目标是找一份工作，对吧？所以以那个为目标，如果某人，你知道，没有，你知道，获得CS学位或他们没有经历那个过程，他们怎么能开始呢？我可以吗？所以我认为CS学位是有用的，但那个用途不是为某人在行业中的工作做准备。计算机科学有一个理论方面，如果你想进入研究并稍微向前移动球门柱，你可能需要学习。对于进入行业，我不认为CS学位对你特别有帮助。我看到CS学位毕业的人，他们一生中从未写过单元测试。哦，是的，可能是大多数。是的。谁无法组织，你知道，
who couldn't be part of a team to save their lives. So you hire someone like that, you know that they have the resolve to sit through four years and, you know, pass some tests, but you also know you're going to have to train them pretty much from scratch. I think a bootcamp is, if you're looking for people who you can actually employ, a bootcamp is a better bet. But I think you also, if you're just starting out and you go to a good bootcamp and you learn both programming and also project stuff, then I think you're way ahead
谁无法成为团队的一部分来拯救他们的生命。所以你雇佣那样的人，你知道他们有决心坐满四年，你知道，通过一些测试，但你也知道你将不得不从头开始训练他们。我认为训练营是，如果你正在寻找你可以真正雇佣的人，训练营是一个更好的赌注。但我认为你也，如果你刚开始，你去一个好的训练营，你既学习编程也学习项目的东西，那么我认为你遥遥领先
of the curve. The trick there is to realize that seven months does not count as experience or as, you know, it doesn't make you an experienced developer. And so once you graduate from a bootcamp, you get your job. That's fantastic. Don't forget that you now have to catch up with your colleagues who have a lot more experience in terms of a whole bunch of stuff, algorithms, languages, techniques, tools, all that kind of thing. And so your bootcamp is basically a way of bootstrapping you into the industry, but that only gets you so far and you have to keep learning after that. Well, and that's really the key right there. The chief ability you need to pick up, whether you do it on your own or from college or university or some other program, you need to
于曲线。那里的诀窍是意识到七个月不算经验，或者作为，你知道，它不会让你成为一个有经验的开发人员。所以一旦你从训练营毕业，你得到你的工作。那太棒了。别忘了你现在必须赶上你的同事，他们在很多方面有更多的经验，算法、语言、技术、工具，所有这些东西。所以你的训练营基本上是一种引导你进入行业的方法，但这只能带你走那么远，在那之后你必须继续学习。嗯，那确实是关键所在。你需要掌握的主要能力，无论你是自己做还是从学院或大学或其他项目中学到，你需要
learn how to learn and how to do so fairly quickly, given the pace of our industry. So, you know, that's one of the advantages, I think, that getting any sort of degree, it doesn't have to be in computer science or information science or anything, but just the, you know, going through the process of getting a degree, you know, usually you'll at least pick up on your own if they don't explicitly teach you how to learn things.
学习如何学习以及如何相当快地做到这一点，鉴于我们行业的步伐。所以，你知道，我认为获得任何学位的好处之一，它不必是计算机科学或信息科学或任何东西，但只是，你知道，经历获得学位的过程，你知道，通常你至少会自己学会，如果他们没有明确教你如何学习事物的话。
You know, make yourself crib notes. Make yourself cheat sheets. Do whatever your technique is. And once you kind of have a feel for that, then the rest of it's much easier. Okay, here's a job you want, and they're using a language you've never used before. All right, well, let me go. Now let me go learn that. Let me go take a course on that or download some YouTube videos
你知道，给自己做小抄。给自己做作弊表。做任何你的技术。一旦你对那个有感觉，那么剩下的就容易多了。好的，这是你想要的工作，他们正在使用一种你以前从未用过的语言。好吧，好吧，让我去。现在让我去学习那个。让我去参加那个课程或下载一些YouTube视频
or buy some books or whatever it might be. Because even once you've gone through that sort of that first hump and gone through the HR process to get you in the door for the first job, that doesn't mean the learning's over, right? You've literally just started. Now you've got to learn the domain and this framework that they're using and this other language that they're using that you didn't know about and on and on and on. So, you know, you really need to be prepared for the constant learning and the constant upkeep, kind of no matter where you start. That really is just the beginning. That makes sense. And I think it ties into the interviewing,
或买一些书或任何它可能是。因为即使一旦你经历了那种那种第一个驼峰并经历了人力资源流程让你进入第一份工作，那并不意味着学习结束了，对吧？你字面上才刚刚开始。现在你必须学习领域和他们正在使用的这个框架以及他们正在使用的这个你不知道的另一种语言，等等等等。所以，你知道，你真的需要为持续的学习和持续的维护做好准备，无论你从哪里开始。那真的只是开始。这说得通。而且我认为它与面试有关，
you know, discussion we had earlier where, you know where the sort of corollary to that is how do companies evaluate all of these different boot camps that don't have sort of this rubber stamp from, I guess, the government, whoever accredits the college accreditation board. board? And I think the answer is then that you have a better interview process so that if someone, if over time you learn that bootcamp XYZ is not really preparing people, you could learn that in the interview. Well, actually many bootcamps now will actually organize for their, typically the last iteration, whatever they call their kind of three or four week cycles, the one before the last will actually go out and work in industry. And they'll have like, you know, companies that are interested in evaluating people and also are prepared to like train them to some extent. And so that's actually a really good way of recruiting, right? So you volunteer, you know, you say to them,
我们之前讨论的讨论，你知道，其中一个推论是公司如何评估所有这些没有那种来自，我猜，政府，任何认证学院认证委员会的橡皮图章的训练营。委员会？我认为答案是，那么你有一个更好的面试过程，这样如果某人，如果随着时间的推移你了解到训练营XYZ并没有真正准备好人们，你可以在面试中了解到这一点。嗯，实际上许多训练营现在实际上会为他们的，通常是最后一次迭代，无论他们称为什么样的三或四周周期，倒数第二次实际上会出去并在行业中工作。而且他们会有，你知道，有兴趣评估人们的公司，也准备好在某种程度上训练他们。所以这实际上是一种非常好的招聘方式，对吧？所以你自愿，你知道，你对他们说，
I'm looking for whatever it might be, a Rails developer. And you go to the bootcamp and say, I'll take one of your Rails developers for three weeks and I'll give you a review at the end on how well they did. And you know what? If you like them, make them a job offer. Yeah, that makes sense. That makes sense.
我正在寻找任何它可能是，一个Rails开发人员。你去训练营说，我会带走你的一个Rails开发人员三周，我会在最后给你一个关于他们做得如何的评论。而且你知道吗？如果你喜欢他们，给他们一个工作机会。是的，这说得通。这说得通。
This happens a lot with interns with interns so it's the equivalent of an internship where somebody is in their final year at university they spend a summer at company xyz and then they get a it becomes more frictionless to to get a full-time job there exactly yeah cool that makes sense what about um i had a topic on top of my mind. Oh yeah. What about working remotely? Um, does the book cover that or is that something that's kind of out of the purview of the book? I know there's a bunch of unique challenges there where you're sort of, you know, the only person in Kansas on your team. That's, that's not something we, we really speak to, um, by itself, but we've done an awful lot of it. Um, I haven't worked, I've not worked in an office for
这在实习生中发生很多，与实习生一起，所以这相当于实习，某人在大学最后一年，他们在公司XYZ度过一个夏天，然后他们得到一个，它变得更顺畅，去那里得到一份全职工作，完全正确，是的，酷，这说得通。关于，嗯，我脑子里有一个话题。哦，是的。关于远程工作怎么样？嗯，书里涵盖了吗，还是那是某种超出书的范围的东西？我知道那里有一堆独特的挑战，你有点，你知道，你团队中在堪萨斯州的唯一一个人。那，那不是我们，我们真正谈论的，嗯，本身，但我们已经做了很多。嗯，我没有工作，我没有在办公室工作过
25 years now or so. Okay. So, you know, that's, we're well acquainted with it, but we didn't, we didn't really address it specifically of, you know, here's the tips and the techniques. I mean, it kind of, it kind of falls under the purview of the other topics of good communication and, you know, those sorts of things. Yeah, that makes sense. Cool. Yeah, this, this is absolutely fascinating. I think, you know, we didn't do sort of this broad overview of the whole book, but I think actually, you know, anyone who sort of listens to this should be extremely inspired to go and read. This is a fascinating book. I'm about, I think, three chapters in.
25年了，左右。好的。所以，你知道，那，我们很熟悉它，但我们没有，我们没有真正专门解决它，你知道，这是提示和技术。我的意思是，它有点，它有点属于良好沟通的其他主题的范围，你知道，那些类型的事情。是的，这说得通。酷。是的，这，这绝对是迷人的。我想，你知道，我们没有做那种整本书的广泛概述，但我认为实际上，你知道，任何听这个的人都应该受到极大的启发去阅读。这是一本迷人的书。我想我大概读了三章。
My plan was to have read the whole thing. I said, oh, while I'm on paternity leave, taking care of this newborn, I'm going to have this book read by today. And that was a bad plan. I think by the end of the book, I'll realize, you know, how I actually messed that one up. Is this your first child? Second one. So. Oh, so you didn't learn the first time. No, that's right. Yeah. I didn't iterate fast enough there. Need to take a bigger, bigger step in the gradient. Well, well, the problem, the problem, of course, with a newborn is you start getting that sleep deprivation
我的计划是读完整个东西。我说，哦，当我在陪产假时，照顾这个新生儿，我今天要把这本书读完。那是一个糟糕的计划。我想在书的结尾，我会意识到，你知道，我实际上是如何搞砸那个的。这是你的第一个孩子吗？第二个。所以。哦，所以你第一次没学到。不，那是对的。是的。我没有在那里迭代得足够快。需要在梯度中采取更大、更大的步骤。嗯，嗯，问题，问题，当然，与新生儿在一起是你开始得到那种睡眠剥夺
hallucinations going on. So yeah, that's right. We'll give you a pass. We'll give you a pass on that. But that is an example of one of those irreversible decisions as well. Yeah, that's true. Definitely a critical decision. There's no going back. So is there a part of the book that you wanted to highlight? Oh, actually, we did want to talk about what's new.
幻觉正在发生。所以是的，那是对的。我们会给你一张通行证。我们会给你一张通行证。但那是那些不可逆转的决定之一的例子。是的，那是真的。绝对是一个关键的决定。没有回头路。所以书里有什么部分你想强调的吗？哦，实际上，我们确实想谈谈有什么新的。
So for people who have the 20th, who have the original version, what can they expect to learn that's different to the 20th anniversary version? Well, to some extent, really, it's a whole new book. We added, I think what we're saying, about a third new content, but there's changes literally on every page from the original, some small, some more major. But you have to consider that the world today of 2019, 2020 is really very much different from the world of 1999 or year 2000. So we tried to reflect that. You know, a lot of stuff changed in technology, a lot of stuff
那么对于那些拥有第20版，也就是原始版本的人来说，他们可以期待学到什么与20周年纪念版不同的东西呢？嗯，在某种程度上，这确实是一本全新的书。我们增加了，我想我们说的是，大约三分之一的新内容，但实际上每一页都与原版有所改动，有些是小的改动，有些则比较重大。但你必须考虑到，2019年、2020年的世界与1999年或2000年的世界确实有很大的不同。所以我们试图反映这一点。你知道，技术方面发生了很多变化，很多事情
changed in attitudes, how you approach certain things. So I, you know, of course, I would say, yes, go out and buy the new book. But and some people say, well, should I get that? Should I read that instead of the first one? And really, it's a it's a I think it's a different experience. I would say you don't need to go if you've never read it you don't need to go out and buy the very first one no i just got the new one but but it is it is not like you know a jack reacher book where you have to read them in order or something you know it's just yeah right it there's a lot of there's a lot of uh i guess let's come back to the original question you say say, you know, what would I learn from reading the book?
在态度上，以及你处理某些事情的方式上都发生了变化。所以我，你知道，当然，我会说，是的，去买这本新书吧。但是，有些人会说，嗯，我应该买那本吗？我应该读那本而不是第一本吗？实际上，这是一种，我认为这是一种不同的体验。我会说，如果你从来没读过，你不需要去买第一本，不，我刚买了新的一本，但它不像杰克·李奇（Jack Reacher）系列小说那样，你必须按顺序阅读，你知道，它只是，是的，没错，有很多，有很多，呃，我想让我们回到最初的问题，你说，你知道，我从读这本书中学到什么？
And the answer is really exactly what Andy and I learned over the last 20 years. Yeah, that makes sense. I mean, one thing that I think personally I've felt very – has changed a lot is open source. I mean, in 2000, there wasn't the kind of open source community that there is now and and some of these silicon valley companies like google um were just way way ahead maybe even a decade ahead of everybody else um now the open source um communities has gotten so big and now i mean most of the big companies are in the open source community so they're pushing it forward that i mean now it's a lot of looking at what's out there versus yeah in 2000 there wasn't that much out there well and it's funny
答案确实就是安迪和我过去20年里学到的东西。是的，这很有道理。我的意思是，我认为我个人感觉变化很大的一点是开源。我的意思是，在2000年，还没有现在这样的开源社区，而且像谷歌这样的一些硅谷公司，嗯，可能比其他人领先很多，甚至领先十年，嗯，现在开源社区已经变得非常庞大，而且我的意思是，大多数大公司都在开源社区中，所以他们在推动它前进，我的意思是，现在更多的是关注现有的东西，而在2000年，并没有那么多东西，嗯，这很有趣
because yeah the net was still new there was no google we used alta vista we used lycos you know those were the search engines um and every time in the in the first edition of the book we would talk about the internet you know with a capital, because it was this new, you know, awesome thing. And so, yeah, we had to tone that down. It's like, oh, of course, just go grab this on the net. And, you know, little things like, you know, in the old days, we'd say, okay, if you wanted to learn this language, hey, this is great. There is an open source implementation of it. You can go and download it and do, you know, make, config, make, make, install, and play with it. And you don't need to do any of that nonsense now, right? You can go online and play in a REPL
因为是的，网络还很新，没有谷歌，我们用AltaVista，我们用Lycos，你知道，那些是搜索引擎，嗯，每次在书的第一版中，我们谈论互联网时，你知道，用大写字母，因为它是一个新的，你知道，很棒的东西。所以，是的，我们不得不淡化这一点。就像，哦，当然，只要在网上抓取这个就行了。而且，你知道，一些小事，比如，你知道，在过去，我们会说，好吧，如果你想学习这种语言，嘿，这太棒了。有一个开源实现。你可以去下载它，然后做，你知道，make，config，make，make install，然后玩它。现在你不需要做任何那种废话了，对吧？你可以上网并在REPL中玩
in any language that you want. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's just there. So yeah, there was a lot of that, those sorts of changes, you know, not having the build machine over in the corner, but being able to do a, you know, just push in your version control system and have a pipeline in the corner, but being able to do a, you know, just push in your version control system and have a pipeline in the cloud, do your continuous integration, build, test, you know, whatever it is. So yeah, there's definitely, I would classify that as sort of added almost attitudinal changes because it is a technical change, but it feels fundamentally different from having, you know, a build machine in the corner versus I'm just doing a commit in my version control and it's just happening. Yeah, there's a scalability or a scale-free nature to that.
任何你想要的语言。是的。是的。是的。它就在那里。所以是的，有很多那种变化，你知道，不需要在角落里放一台构建机器，而是能够做，你知道，只需推送到你的版本控制系统中，在云端有一个流水线，做你的持续集成、构建、测试，你知道，无论是什么。所以是的，我肯定会把这归类为某种增加的几乎是态度上的变化，因为它是一个技术上的变化，但它感觉与在角落里放一台构建机器相比，本质上是不同的，而我只是在我的版本控制中做一个提交，它就发生了。是的，这有一种可扩展性或无标度特性。
I mean, we have one project I work on. Every time there's a commit on any branch where there's, I don't know, there's probably thousands of them or at least hundreds of them a day, it goes through and in the cloud does an integration test. That'd be totally impractical if you had to have the machines yourself by your desk. Sure. I think there's another side to it, though, and that is that the proliferation of open source has meant that choosing technologies has now become something of a nightmare. And many developers are faced with this.
我的意思是，我们有一个我工作的项目。每次在任何分支上有提交时，我不知道，可能有成千上万个，或者至少每天有几百个，它就会通过并在云端进行集成测试。如果你必须在办公桌旁自己拥有这些机器，那将是完全不切实际的。当然。不过，我认为还有另一面，那就是开源的激增意味着选择技术现在已经成为一种噩梦。许多开发人员面临着这个问题。
It's the start of a project. What is the JavaScript framework this week? Yep, yep. And I think that in the face of this bounty, this like excess of opportunity, it takes a lot of discipline to say, I don't need to be using the latest and greatest. And the teams who are the most effective
这是一个项目的开始。本周的JavaScript框架是什么？是的，是的。我认为面对这种慷慨，这种过剩的机会，需要很大的纪律性才能说，我不需要使用最新最好的东西。而那些最有效的团队
are the ones that find something that works for them and obviously periodically review to make sure it is still working. But don't worry about the fads. Don't worry about this latest thing they read about on Stack Overflow or whatever. And just to keep thinking about the fundamentals. The fact that nowadays you can
是那些找到适合自己的东西，并显然定期审查以确保它仍然有效的人。但不要担心那些时尚。不要担心他们在Stack Overflow或其他地方读到的最新东西。只需继续思考基本原理。事实上，现在你可以
put together a thousand node cloud computer system managed with a database and with an operating system and with compilers and with libraries and with everything else and not spend a cent apart from processor time. It's unbelievable. It's an incredible opportunity. And the trick to utilizing that, I think, is to be efficient and effective and really pretty intensely focused on what it is you're trying to do and not how you're trying to do it. Yep. I know personally, I get a lot of analysis paralysis when I start a new project, especially something in, let's say, web, where there's so many different technologies, and you could spend an entire day reading about React versus Angular, and people have probably a whole career based on writing about that. And what's even worse, I find, is that I'm in
组建一个由一千个节点组成的云计算机系统，用数据库、操作系统、编译器、库和其他一切来管理，除了处理器时间外，不花一分钱。这令人难以置信。这是一个不可思议的机会。我认为利用这一点的诀窍是高效、有效，并且真正非常专注于你试图做什么，而不是你试图怎么做。是的。我个人知道，当我开始一个新项目时，我会有很多分析瘫痪，特别是在，比如说，Web领域，那里有太多不同的技术，你可能会花一整天时间阅读React与Angular的对比，人们可能整个职业生涯都是基于写这个。而且我发现更糟糕的是，我处于
the middle of a project, and it's not working. And there's this human reaction, which is, well, it can't be my fault, right? So it must be this framework. And it's really hard to resist that temptation to say, okay, I'm going to dump React and go to Vue and see what happens if I do that, you know? And I see a lot of people doing that. And I got to say, actually, I don't think that's a bad thing at a certain point. I mean, obviously, if you're far down the path and months and months into the project, maybe that's not such a great idea. But if it's early stages and you're prototyping and you're learning and you don't know, well, would Angular be best for this particular application? Or should I use Vue or should I use React or whatever today's latest entry is, you know, try something simple in each one. Try something
项目进行到一半，它无法工作。有一种人类的反应，那就是，嗯，这不可能是我的错，对吧？所以一定是这个框架的问题。要抵制那种说，好吧，我要放弃React转而使用Vue，看看如果我这样做会发生什么的诱惑，真的很难，你知道吗？我看到很多人这样做。我必须说，实际上，我不认为在某种程度上这是一件坏事。我的意思是，显然，如果你已经走得很远，项目已经进行了好几个月，也许这不是一个好主意。但如果是在早期阶段，你正在进行原型设计和学习，你不知道，嗯，Angular最适合这个特定的应用程序吗？或者我应该使用Vue，或者我应该使用React，或者无论今天最新的条目是什么，你知道，在每一个中尝试一些简单的东西。尝试一些
complicated in each one and, you know, give it a go. See what you learn from that. See which you think would be easier to maintain, which would be easier to, you know, to deal with. You know, too often, whatever we are faced with, whether it's an architectural decision or a design decision, we kind of go with whatever our first instinct is. Okay, well, here's a way to solve this. Let's do that. And that becomes the direction. So I'll leave you all with a challenge.
在每一个中都很复杂，你知道，试一试。看看你从中能学到什么。看看你认为哪一个更容易维护，哪一个更容易，你知道，处理。你知道，太频繁了，无论我们面临什么，无论是架构决策还是设计决策，我们都会倾向于我们的第一直觉。好吧，这是一种解决这个问题的方法。让我们这样做吧。这就成了方向。所以我给你们所有人留下一个挑战。
You know, when you're in that situation, think of at least three different ways you could do it. Think of three different frameworks. Think of three different algorithms. Think of three different frameworks. Think of three different algorithms. Think of three different approaches. And try as much of each one as you can and see what that tells you. See what you can learn from that. Yeah, that makes sense. I think also things are much more transferable than we believe. I think when we start out, we have this big fear of missing out. That if we don't do it and react then we'll get to some point we'll be totally
你知道，当你处于那种情况时，想想至少三种你可以做到的不同方法。想想三个不同的框架。想想三个不同的算法。想想三个不同的框架。想想三个不同的算法。想想三种不同的方法。并尽可能多地尝试每一种，看看它告诉你什么。看看你能从中学习到什么。是的，这很有道理。我认为事情也比我们相信的更具可转移性。我认为当我们开始时，我们有一种巨大的错失恐惧症（FOMO）。如果我们不在React中做，那么我们就会到达某个点，我们会完全
stuck and the reality is it never really works that way um you know most of the even if worst case you have to completely rewrite it in a different language that's going to be much much faster than yeah because because now you know what it's supposed to do and you know they call it software for a reason it is soft soft. You can change it. Oh, I thought it was because it was wearing. On that note. Cool. Well, this is amazing.
卡住，而现实是它从来不是那样工作的，嗯，你知道，大多数即使最坏的情况是你必须用不同的语言完全重写它，那也会快得多，是的，因为因为现在你知道它应该做什么，而且你知道他们称之为软件是有原因的，它是软的，软的。你可以改变它。哦，我还以为是因为它在磨损。说到这里。酷。嗯，这太棒了。
So if people want to, you know, get the book, where would they go? If they've read the book, how can they contact you folks? How does that part work so the ebook is available directly from us at pragprog.com which is short for pragmatic programmer you go to pragprog.com and that's our publishing business we've got hundreds of titles in print that other authors have written that we've published over the years. And you can get the 20th anniversary of the Pragmatic Programmer in PDF, Mobi, and EPUB format, all for one price, directly from pragprog.com. And then on September 19th, 2019, the hardback, we're going hardcover this time. Oh, really?
所以如果人们想要，你知道，买这本书，他们应该去哪里？如果他们读过这本书，他们怎么联系你们？那部分是怎么运作的？所以电子书可以直接从我们的pragprog.com获得，这是pragmatic programmer的缩写，你去pragprog.com，那是我们的出版业务，我们有数百种其他作者写的书，是我们多年来出版的。你可以直接从pragprog.com以一个价格获得PDF、Mobi和EPUB格式的《程序员修炼之道》20周年纪念版。然后在2019年9月19日，精装本，我们这次要出精装本。哦，真的吗？
Yeah. Well, we figured so many people kind of complained that, you know, their books were getting all dog-eared from lending it out to folks and rereading it and reading it again and carting it around. You know, they were taking some heavy damage on the cover. So we figured, all right, we'd give it a fighting chance this go-round. So the 20th edition is a nice hardback, you know, suitable for stuffing in your backpack and kicking around the coffee table. Nice. And that'll be in all the sort of regular Dead Tree bookstores, Amazon, Barnes & Noble. If you've got a local bookstore, please patronize them.
是的。嗯，我们想，很多人抱怨说，你知道，他们的书因为借给别人、重读、再读以及随身携带而变得卷边了。你知道，封面受到了严重的损坏。所以我们想，好吧，这次我们要给它一个战斗的机会。所以第20版是一本漂亮的精装书，你知道，适合塞进你的背包，在咖啡桌上踢来踢去。不错。那将会在所有那种常规的纸质书店、亚马逊、巴诺书店有售。如果你有当地的书店，请光顾他们。
We like to keep them in business. Cool. And how can people reach you and Dave if they want to talk to you folks? You can find us both on Twitter. Dave's at PragDave. I'm at PragmaticAndy. That's probably the best way to get a hold of us. Cool.
我们喜欢让他们继续经营。酷。如果人们想和你以及戴夫谈谈，他们怎么联系你们？你们可以在Twitter上找到我们俩。戴夫是@PragDave。我是@PragmaticAndy。那可能是联系我们最好的方式。酷。
Cool. Thank you so much again for coming on the show. And yeah, everyone, so check out pragprog.com. And we'll put a link to that in the show notes. You can grab your copy of the book there or at your local bookstore. When does it, when does it hit bookstores? Uh, the, so September 19th is the official publication date. It'll be available on, uh, informit.com at least at that date. And I believe Amazon within a few days or a week after that. And then it sort of
酷。再次非常感谢你们来到节目。是的，大家，去看看pragprog.com。我们会在节目说明中放一个链接。你可以在那里或在当地书店买到你的书。它什么时候，什么时候上市？嗯，9月19日是正式出版日期。至少在那天它会在informit.com上提供。我相信亚马逊会在那之后的几天或一周内上架。然后它会某种程度上
diffuses through the ecosystem. So, you know, other places in the U.S. will have it within a week or so. Internationally, it might take a few weeks to get to your country. Cool. Cool. So for that for that for that boss you have who still wants people to invert a binary tree for the interview, you could give it to him for Christmas. It'll be there. Absolutely. Makes a great Christmas present christmas present all right cool thank you again for coming on the show thanks for having us the intro music is axo by biner pilot programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attrib Share Alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work,
扩散到整个生态系统中。所以，你知道，美国其他地方会在一周左右的时间内有货。在国际上，可能需要几周时间才能到达你的国家。酷。酷。所以对于那个仍然想让人们在面试中反转二叉树的老板，你可以在圣诞节送给他。它会在那里的。绝对。是一个很棒的圣诞礼物，圣诞礼物，好的，酷，再次感谢你们来到节目，谢谢你们邀请我们，片头音乐是Biner Pilot的Axo，Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下分发的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行混音、改编作品，
but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但你必须注明我和帕特里克的出处，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。